CATHERINE DRENNAN:
So I'm Cathy Drennan.
I'm a professor of chemistry
and biology here at MIT.
I'm also a professor and
investigator with the Howard
Hughes Medical
Institute, and I've
been teaching freshman
chemistry here at MIT,
particularly a course called
511.1 since I started in 1999.
So I've always loved
education, and when
I started at Vassar
College, I went
there to study either
drama or biopsychology.
I mentioned I'm a
chemist and a biologist.
You're like, what
happened there?
So I went there
and I didn't really
know what I wanted to study.
And they said, oh
well, if you're
thinking of anything biology,
you have to take chemistry.
And I said, oh no.
Please don't make
me take chemistry.
I took it in high school.
I can tell you it has absolutely
nothing to do with biology.
It's deadly, dull,
don't make me.
Well, I had to
take it, and I took
it freshman year,
first semester,
and fell in love with chemistry.
And I realized it was
about teaching and how
one teacher could really make
such an enormous difference.
I became interested in teaching.
Vassar College actually had
no research at that point.
So my Summers I had
to do something else.
I couldn't work in
the research lab.
And so I was a summer
camp counselor, and eight
through 12-year-olds.
And I taught them about botany
and all sorts of other things,
and I was like, this is great.
So I signed up to take
education classes.
And my advisor in chemistry was
like, what now with this thing
I'm signing?
You're taking this
education course?
What is this?
But I was just absolutely
in love with it.
And then when it was
time for graduation,
I thought about
applying to grad school,
but I wasn't really quite sure.
And I wanted to really try
out this teaching thing
and see what I thought of it.
So I got a job
teaching high school,
and I taught high school
at a Quaker boarding
school and working hog farm.
And you have to understand,
I'm from New York.
And New York and New Jersey,
I can be an hour away
from New York City.
That was OK.
And then I was going to Iowa.
So I packed up and moved to Iowa
to this Quaker boarding school,
and I taught chemistry,
biology, and physics and drama.
So that came in handy.
I did end up taking some drama.
And I absolutely loved it.
But as a high school
teacher, I really
wanted to enrich the curriculum.
And I was looking for
things to say, oh,
you need to learn
this in chemistry
because the big question that
scientists are trying to answer
right now is this thing.
And you need to know
this to do that.
But I didn't really know
what this thing was.
So I felt like-- and I
tried to get other material
to learn more about
the world of research.
But there just wasn't very
much good material out there,
especially for chemistry.
And so I went to grad school
at University of Michigan,
and I thought, OK, I'll learn
about the world of research
and I'll go back and
teach high school.
And so I just tell people
that I got slightly distracted
on my pathway to do that.
But I ended up at
MIT and teaching here
is such a wonderful experience.
I mean, the students are
absolutely incredible.
And I've found a home.
I can run a research
group, but I also can just
have a fantastic time teaching.
And so that's my
unusual path, I guess,
to teaching this course at MIT.